people must be excited when you go home
Brookline that's a friendly town they
must be excited when oh great Frankie's
back in town you have a show it's a
success well my family's from Southie
mm-hmm and you know people from Boston
they keep things close to the chest
they're not like feeling they're not a
motive people right but they're excited
in their own way you know my brother
refuses to buy Showtime but he steals
showtime online somehow so he's watching
it he just won't pay for it right so I
mean but like I'll still get um the
annual letter from my uncle in the year
Neal handwritten asking me what my plan
B is like every year around here so yeah
I so good I was two years into my late
night show and I had an uncle say I
really think you should think of law
school yeah no joke that was I was like
it was like 1995 and he was like I still
think you'd make a good lawyer and I'm
like I have my TV show they're caring
it's just like comes out my aunt though
she didn't come to my wedding because
she didn't want to fly on an airplane by
herself
but then came to the premiere of Smith
out here in LA so I mean that was also
her way of supporting yeah that's so
cool yeah now the show is a big success
for Showtime how does your mom feel
about the show - she does she liked the
show oh yeah she's so proud she loves
the show we just got picked up for a
second season
yes he's been calling me with pitches
for episode ideas oh yeah so yeah I get
voicemails call me back I got an idea
and so she wants me to get pregnant in
my real life and so she now wants the
character to get pregnant so then we can
be filming while pregnant and not have
to do what they did on scandal as her
whole point wait so she just wants you
to have a kid yeah so her creative idea
for the show that you in real life have
a grandchild for yeah yeah she's also I
guess I'm distantly related to Denis
Leary who was just here which I didn't
know how but so she wants me to find
Denis who I just met in the hallway tell
him were related and then get him to
play my uncle on the show so then one
that's very weird creative ideas they
don't they don't seem to come from a
place of what would be good for the show
I don't even know if we're really
related like I think there's so I texted
my aunt Moe to get the scoop I'm gonna
tell you what she texted this is how
you're related to Denis Leary yeah is
this an app so we're all related to
Denis yeah just punch in they get your
Denis Leary app there so I texted her
last night how are we related to Denis
Leary and she writes back my dad your
grandfather I have to do it her she owes
my dad your grandfather and namesake is
Dennis's mother's first cousin so your
great-grandmother in Genesis grandmother
on his mother's side with sisters I
think he might know uncle Billy Billy
keeps in touch with Dennis's mom last I
heard so I didn't understand that
yeah well then five minutes later she
goes so Dennis is he a second cousin
once-removed I did the research yeah so
that's what the deal is very nice yeah
I'm glad we cleared that out it's
important
you